les nouveaux prix nobel de littérature
samir amin
la ville de sidi mimoun est heureuse de
vous inviter au sein de vos nommé
citoyen d'honneur
c'est mon reconnaît meadows oui le tube
voisins oui avec les cheveux longs j'ai
pas changer un nom à toi ta vie' un
petit peu monsieur normal c'est la
france ici c'est là toute façon moi j'ai
pas de voiture parce que je n'ai pas de
permis
d'abaisser jeudi l'algérie ça fait
combien de temps que tu est parvenu au
bled je sais mais 25 ans oh non embauche
on trouve des chefs tu discutes avec lui
qui le chef lui est là avec les roms
corps lui lynx et les réparer les dégâts
par ap six amis
nous sommes très honorés de vous écrire
par mail en hiver parce qu'ils gagnent
camerino attend quelques noms
[Musique]
on est très fiers de vous en algérie
mais est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
bien raconter impayés alors qu'on vous à
l'étranger j'ai vécu ici jusqu'à l'âge
de 20 ans janes des traces commun
[Musique]
la famille amis joris j'aime beaucoup ta
famille depuis qu'il a quitté le pays il
n'apprend les algériens que du mépris et
de rêve
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tu es revenu ne dis pas que
c'est pour recevoir une médaille
savez vous aviez fait les manifestations
étudiantes en 88 ça vous dit pas de
venir manifester avec nous j'ai passé
l'âge grand mais quoi il n'y a pas d'âge
pour manifester
[Musique]
jurai je remettrai plus jamais les pieds
ici
je suis là
quand général de gaulle et la fête des
secours je n'ai rien compris je vous ai
compris
[Musique]